théo est étudiant en communication il
recherche une alternance
pour mettre toutes les chances de son
côté il participe à un coaching
personnalisé pour perfectionner ses
candidatures c'est très intéressant en
fait d'avoir un avis de quelqu'un qui ne
vous connaît pas et qui va pouvoir juger
de
votre performance de manière
extrêmement objective en fait souvent
les personnes que je vois sont trop
modestes et met pas en avant leurs
qualités c'est incroyable c'est vraiment
incroyable
on va toutes les qualités après son
coaching chaque participant peut faire
le tour de la quarantaine de stands qui
composent le forum de l'apprentissage
organisé par la cfdt
pour cette cinquième édition le syndicat
a choisi trappe
notre objectif était vraiment de mettre
en relation les jeunes ou des quartiers
alors pas forcément défavorisés mais où
il y avait une certaine discrimination
et un fort taux de chômage pour leur
ouvrir notre réseau à
et leur ferme à
avoir un emploi un stage l'alternance
c'est pas bon qu'on envoie un cv en
ligne par exemple on n'aura pas de
réponse en fait on est devant la
personne tout de suite et à prendre
votre cv donc du coup certains 6.60
année l'événement en partenariat avec
pôle emploi convoque plusieurs acteurs
de l'emploi des entreprises qui
recrutent mais aussi des associations
comme aprodema elle propose de découvrir
les métiers de l'agroéquipement on
estime qu'ils nous manquent à peu près
6000 emplois qui restent non pourvus
chaque année d'ailleurs général non par
exemple un jeune qu'information dans les
formations vos équipements à la fin il
entre deux et trois offres minimum
d'emploi pour ce délit bien sûr lors de
la dernière édition du forum à nanterre
250 personnes avaient trouvé un emploi